hello everyone and welcome to a really
awesome game from the penultimate round
of the super bet chess classic it's
bogdan daniel deak versus levon aronyan
and it's uh again like i said a really
well thought game and it features one
move that really
just blew my mind so hopefully you guys
will enjoy it as well uh but before we
get to the actual game i would just like
to mention
uh regarding the previous video and the
nikhil kamat uh controversy
uh as usual i do the video as soon as
you know something happens in the world
of chess and i started receiving a lot
of emails how this is uh you know really
awesome game how
an incredible thing happened and
although uh
you you don't think someone would would
use an engine you you simply don't i
mean
if we just go around pointing fingers
you're using an engine you're using an
engine then
it kind of all falls apart especially
since now 99
of chest being played is online chess so
everyone could be using an engine so
uh i don't know it feels like uh
everyone should be given the benefit of
the doubt
but um even though okay it's very easy
to say okay 99 points
or whatever 98.9 percent accuracy
that was played in the game against
anand uh of course it sounds a very
incredible and fishy
is it impossible of course not it could
be possible i don't know i've never
heard of the guy
uh he might be playing uh you know
online chess 24 7
in his not 24 24 7 but he could be
playing
all the time in his spare time so like i
said as usual i
i make the video as soon as i hear the
news and um
well in the end he he he didn't
apologize on twitter he kind of said
that he was
all done in good spirits but uh okay
uh to maybe uh
if he's not a chess player maybe he
doesn't realize how
how big of a deal this is uh using using
an engine
especially you know against a guy like
like on and the five-time world champion
uh especially in a charity event but um
i don't know seems like there was really
no no reason to do such a thing
uh but yeah just wanted to get that uh
out in the open but uh you know it just
puts uh
puts a sour taste uh
after after you know uh witnessing
something like that because
we want uh you know great things to
happen in the world of chess and we want
miracles to happen and this you know uh
especially with anand
resigning and allowing him to have the
win because without that
anan basically just crushed crushed
stockfish here
so it really just all felt in in good
gesture and you know it felt like
everyone was having a good time
i was watching the stream i i had no
idea what was happening i just received
a bunch of emails and thought it was a
a really good story but uh as it turns
out uh
the the the gentleman was using uh
computer assistance
and that's how he was able to uh take
down former world
champion vishwanathan and so no miracles
uh occurred yesterday
so that being said uh let's check out
this game so
yeah diac versus arunyan let's see what
happens here so uh with the white pieces
the akk opens with e4
we have c5 going for the sicilian
defense knight to f3
d6 and now uh bishop to b5 with check
going for the rosso limo attack knights
to d7 and now
d4 now you don't mind even capturing
with the queen on d4 because there is no
knight
on c6 to kick away the queen so here we
have c captures queen captures and
now a6 pushing the bishop back bishop
back to a
e2 and now knight to g to f6 uh levon
continues developing we have castles
and now uh e6
uh and it's interesting that this
position uh
occurred uh only a handful of times and
in all of the games they were played
white did not win a single game so most
of the games were won by black pieces
and i think
white got a draw in one of them uh but
here the ark wants to change this and
uh here he plays rook to d1 uh
you could also consider a move like c4
going for this sort of a
marathi type structure i don't know
whenever i get the chance i always like
to get that
c4 move in but he has a different plan
he plays rook to d1
and this is now a new move in the
position so already
as of move 8 we have a completely new
game uh so here bishop to e7 eleven just
continues developing
and now again not interested in going
for this structure
knight to c3 we have queen to c7
and now comes a4 and here probably the
reason why he prefers the pawn on c2
instead of on c4 as this is kind of a
counter-intuitive uh is that he wants to
play queen to c4 at some point and
trade or trade off queens here so here
we have castles and
a5 now grabbing more space here uh we
have
rook to d8 and now comes bishop to e3 so
both players just nicely continuing
development
we have knight to g4 now attacking the
bishop here
and you do not want to give up your your
dark square bishop so bishop to g5
knight back to g and knight g back to f6
and now
he probably wanted to check if bishop
back to e3 was going to be played in uh
not uh not that he was interested in a
draw or anything he's fighting for first
place
and after that uh lost uh uh mamadyarov
he really has to
give it all his gut so here queen to c4
offering this uh queen trade we have
queen captures on c for
bishop captures and now uh b5
now it doesn't matter if you play b6 or
b5 uh same thing will happen this is a
move you play no questions asked
so here a capture 7 b6 alpha song and
now uh
knight captures on b6 attacking the axe
bishop here
bishop back to e2 and now bishop to b7
so
for the moment okay the pawn is attacked
twice but it's not really a problem as
the bishop here would would hang
we have knight to d2 now preparing to
improve this structure with a move like
f3 we've rooked to d7
now preparing to double up rooks and the
c file and
bishop to d3 adding more support here we
have rook to c7
and now comes f3 so here again
this pawn still remains in c2 dark
prefers this setup with the bishop on d3
and now
this pawn will be defended with with the
bishop
so here we have d5 and d5 again
if you've been following this channel
for for some time you know that i always
say whenever black
gets a chance to execute that d5 in the
sicilian then all is well for him
so let's see how the game continues we
have bishop to e3
and level now happily exchanges here we
have d captures on e4
and now knight d captures an e4 you
could also consider bishop captures on
b6
saying that okay but now your rook is
also under attack but just rook c6
and now black will uh win either the
light square or the dark square bishop
so after something like knight c
captures on e4 you're going to capture
here and yes the material is
equal but uh black still has the bishop
pair he has a very active rook he's soon
going to have another very active rook
and
it's going to be it it's going to be you
know it's an okay position for both
white and black but
i i don't know one might prefer this
with the black pieces so here
after d captures on e4 we have knight d
captures on e4 instead and now
knight f2d5 uh we have bishop to d4 of
course
your bishop still hangs here and now f6
just well it's a very useful move
numbing numbing this
bishop on on d4 and at some point if you
want you can even
execute e5 so here we have b3
now if this knight moves maybe now we
can finally get the c4 move in
and if you look at the position uh the
material is still completely equal but
the dock
is the only one with the pass pawn so if
this c pawn starts marching forward
and he does have plenty of support to do
so could be could be very interesting
so here king f7 levon improves the
position of the king and now
knight captures on the e5 we have knight
captures on d5
and now again not going for c4 but first
bishop to c4
so what do you play here here levon
played a5 and now with the idea of a4
which would
uh either create a pass pawn for him
or if b captures of course you're just
going to lose the bishop on c4
so here we have c3 now the c3 pawn is
defended so
it's not a problem we can capture here
uh and now
yeah if we go a4 which levon did not
play then we simply
trade everything off bishop captures
bishop captures and then now rook
captures on a4
so we can do this because the c3 pawn is
now nicely defended and if bishop
captures on b3
we're just going to play bishop captures
and now rook captures and now bishop
captures on d1 and we get this position
where black is is okay perfectly fine
might be even better but
then it's not much to look forward to so
instead we have g5
elements starts increasing the pressure
on the king side and now
rook to a4 a nice rook lift leaving the
option of maybe doubling rooks on the a
file we have f5 uh forcing this knight
to move
knight back to g3 and now uh not
grabbing more space with f4 but rather
bishop to c5 and here we have a nice uh
capture fest in the center bishop
captures and see
five rook captures bishop captures and
bishop captures and here dax said all
right now i've traded everything off
this is very easy to hold only now will
i
execute this c4 move so it took some
time for this to happen but now it is on
the board
and this is now a past pawn it was a
pass pawn for quite a while but now
it finally started moving so here bishop
to c6 pushing this rook back
rook to a3 and now a4
uh you have to do this to break white's
pawn structure so if white
pushes then you can capture this or if
white captures then you can capture this
and you will
uh not have all that um all that much
trouble
uh dealing with the the past a pawn so
here we have rook d
to a1 but it's not a problem this rook
is not needed here so
rook to g8 and this is uh
this is how 11 starts uh creating so
here we have b
captures on a4 and now comes not
captures on c4 you can always play this
first comes g4 and now the the problem
is if white just
ignores this starts pushing on the queen
side then you can open up the position
here
uh and that's it the black just wins if
you capture this then f4 wins the knight
it's pinned cannot move
uh there's not much for white to play
here so instead after g4 we have
f4 not allowing the g file to open up
and only now
rook captures on c4 so now you you could
start pushing but first uh your f pawn
is hanging so knights the e2 will defend
the pawn and now
rook to b8 now levon wants to bring the
rook to b2 and put
more pressure uh to the to the white
king so here we have rook 3 to a2
preventing this but now
bishop to d5 now after the rook moves
this rook comes under attack
uh but white says there is no good
square for this rook to move to so
a5 uh we rook c to b4 now doubling on
the b
file now preparing bishop to b2 also the
rook is now under attack so rook to d2
and now rook to b2 attacking the rook
the rook is undefended
and now while you could trade here for
example captures and captures now
the knight is under attack if you move
the knight then the g2 pawn is under
attack so you have to play something
like king f2 but now we play bishop to
c4
attack the knight twice and after the
knight is defended we can play rook to
a2 pick up this pawn
we're going to be up upon and we're
going to have a well a very very
good game here with black whether it's
enough to win uh for levon probably
so here after rook to b2 we have rook 8
the d1
just defending the rook on d2 but now
rook captures with rook captures and
rook to a8 and now with the bishop
covering the a2 square
the rook cannot join the defense of the
of the a pawn so here knights the c3
with a double attack on the bishop but
just rook captures on a5 and
this is this is what it took for lewand
to win the pawn
and now he's up upon and he will try to
push this for for a full point
so here uh king to f2 dak also starts
improving the position of his king
uh you could also and probably many
people would just trade here
with with captures captures and then
just move the rook because uh well yeah
black is up upon uh you want to play a
rook end game you do not want to play
a a minor piece end game you do not want
to exchange rooks and then allow black
to be up upon uh
with minor pieces on the board so this
seems like an idea but he decides that
the knight will will come in handy he
starts with king to f2
and now levon says thank you thank you
for this opportunity and now he moves
the bishop saying you will not be
capturing this bishop
anytime soon so here knights the d1
and now comes rook to a4 again putting
pressure on this f4 pawn we have g3 and
now
rook to a1 so now if this knight moves
then you can infiltrate via rook to h1
and then
pick up the h2 pawn and interestingly
this is exactly what the dark does
he plays knight to b2 and he allows this
he wants to create a
sort of a sort of a barrier here for for
uh
for lavon you could play something like
rook to c2 and again try to go for this
rook's end game and then for example if
rook captures rook captures
rook today to check king g1 no maybe yes
okay
you are in a rook's end game your
opponent is up only one pawn
but the king is here completely cut off
from the game he's not entering the game
anytime soon and could be
could be possible to to maybe find
something here for black
uh but instead after rook day one doc
makes it a little bit easier for the one
he plays knight to b2 and now levon
again says
thank you for this yet another
opportunity and plays rook to h1
so now this pawn will fall uh we have
knight to d3
now uh interestingly uh you could also
play king to e3 but
he didn't to kind of keep an eye on this
pawn he just played knights to d3 going
after this knight the e5
check uh but first levon picks up the
the
the pawn with check king to e3 and now
rook captures
on d2 so just uh getting the rooks of
the board king captures and king to e7
and this is the position that dak
decided that he will hold he's down two
pawns but he has a very very active
position knight to e5 he's gonna play
king to e3
and uh levon only has a light square
bishop and all of his pawns are on light
square so here he says
uh your bishop can't do anything to my
point your king
cannot approach my pawns how how how are
you gonna win this game
so let's see what happened here king to
d6 king e3 and the dark is very happy he
says okay you cannot pass
we have king to d5 king to d3 we have
bishop to e8
now nicely controlling this knight but
also controlling the very important
h5 square here so here king back to e3
now h5 we have knight to d3 and now
king to c4 knights to e5 check doc
simply repeats the moves
king to c3 knights to d3 and now levon
plays
h4 and now the bishop here will be
extremely handy because you do not want
to allow white's pass pawn to start
marching forward so here
you do not want to allow h3 that's also
just losing so we have to play g
captures on h3 and now g3 getting this
pass pawn in
and now the thing is the king is
attacking the knight so
uh dak cannot attack the g3 pawn as he
would lose the knight so first we have
to
move the knight knight to e5 and now uh
this is a problem uh the knight uh has
to come to c1 the c1 and then
uh the thread is knight to e2 check
which would win the g3 pawn
and then if you play something like
bishop to h5 uh it's still not a problem
we're just going to play knight's day
to check to pick up the pawn and if we
trade then the king can
easily now reach this pawn and uh this
pawn will now be winning so this would
even be winning for white
if leon would uh would uh go go for this
trade after
after knight to c1 uh he would have to
go for something like g2
and then you know just play play this
two to a draw but
uh luckily for him after g3 knights the
e5 was played but
even this is pretty incredible as you
have to be super super precise to win
this
so feel free to pause the video here and
to win the game for lavon while i give
you a couple of seconds
[Music]
so uh for those of you who are able to
do it congratulations on being a true
master of the end game there is only one
move that wins this position
and for those of you who just want to
enjoy the show it's bishop to h5
and now you see what's happening now the
bishop
the pawn and the king are controlling
all of these squares in front of the
white king and the white king has
nowhere to go
all of these squares are covered uh and
uh he is simply stuck there
there there is nowhere to go so only the
knight can move here
we have knight to d7 and now comes a
move that
levon really played uh well dare i say
it
like an engine uh because it's uh it's
so
such a brute force move that uh i again
urge you to pause the video and try to
find
this while i give you a couple of
seconds
so uh for those of you who are able to
do it congratulations on spotting this
uh well another incredible idea and for
those who just want to enjoy the show
it's
pawn to e5 and uh for this move uh
to be played you really have to you
really have to calculate everything and
uh
sam i suggested on twitter that whenever
player whenever a player plays such a
strong move that
you know uh an engine would play that's
really a top
uh move recommended by the engine uh
that i should award a nikhil kamath head
for the for the occasion so here uh i am
awarding the nikhil kamat head for such
a
such a strong engine move to levon uh
for for
finding this brilliancy so there we have
it hope you guys enjoyed that
if you haven't you know uh mention it to
some eye that his ideas are bad
uh but otherwise you know uh all is good
i thought it was pretty funny
uh but yeah e5 is incredibly strong
because uh
what do you do here again the king
cannot move uh or
uh and what do you do here
uh instead of e5 you could do something
like king to c2 just to show you
what would happen then you allow
whites to escape because now you allow
knight to f6 you attack the bishop
and once the bishop moves and now you
start pushing your pass pawn and that's
it this is enough for a draw
if for example e5 we're just going to
play h6 e captures on f4 king captures
g2
h7 and now we both get a queen and this
is enough for white to draw the game
however in the game with e5 now you
don't have such luxury because what do
you play here
now if you try to repeat the same idea
knight to f6
you are one tempo faster so e captures
on f4 uh sorry first we're going to move
the bishop and then
after the pawn moves and now we're going
to play e captures on f4 with check
king captures and g2 and we are much
faster now if h6 uh we're just gonna
bring a queen into the game if h7
queen g7 you stop promotion everything
is working out for black
uh easy win so instead after e5 you have
to capture it
knight captures and e5 was played but
now comes king to c2 and now
uh it's uh it's very much different
because again you don't have a move all
of these squares are taken from the
white king
uh what do you play here knight to d3
was played but here
king d won by level one and it was in
this position on move 62 that
uh bogdan daniel de arc uh resigned to
the game
as there is nothing more to be done here
uh yes it seems like the black king
cannot approach and if you start pushing
the pawn the king will stop it by
playing king
to f2 but you just have to prevent king
f2 and that's it
and by playing king to d1 you've done
that
because now uh either the king moves to
d4
and then you're able to enter the game
or you can just push g2 and that's
winning
or you have to move the knight but that
also doesn't help if you move the knight
then you release the e1 square king e1
can be played not an id3 check king f1
and now we're gonna
push our pawn to victory as the king is
not uh
the king cannot approach the df2 square
so
really incredible game play uh nicely
followed by both of them
and it's uh interesting uh doc made some
very interesting choices
uh throughout the game uh one of the
more interesting ones was just allowing
lavon to grab that h2 pawn
but okay he thought that maybe maybe he
will be able to hold this because
uh the the position was as it was but uh
in the end
uh lavon was uh if there's a chance to
create something
on the board he he of course will create
it
uh so this was the pen ultimate round
going into the final round uh shakhtar
mahmoud is leading the tournament with
five and a half points and he's followed
by lavon arunian alexander richie and
wesley so with four and a half points so
it's interesting uh
what will happen in the final round
we'll check it out and see who will win
at the super bet uh uh
the super bet uh chess classic
tournament yeah
that's the game hope you guys enjoyed it
i would like to thank happy birthday as
paul
uh avijit banerjeet sankatsola western
carpet cleaning in corporate and aiza
garuda for a contribution to my channel
thank you a lot i really appreciate it
as usual you can check two of my
previous videos here thank you for
watching and i will see you soon
continuing the coverage of this very
nice tournament checking up on your
wonderful suggestions
and whatever else happens in the chess
world so thank y'all i will see you soon
and have an excellent rest of your day